what was the behavior that I exhibited
that you identified as beta just so I
have some clarity because I think you
called me a beta or something like that
um I you know it's I don't think that
was that just like flicking boogers to
get attention or was there something
behind that no I do I I listen I do
think that there is something to be said
about Alpha men and I do think that
certain men are alphas and generally
Alpha men aren't out telling women that
they hit a wall at 23 I do think what's
an alpha man what is one can you define
Alpha Man for us before good on that
tangent sure um let's see Alpha in the
alpha in the wild is something very
specific so in every um species pretty
much you have some type of alpha
Behavior you can look at I don't know
gorillas and you know who the alpha is
he's the one that controls kind of the
narrative he's the one that's the the
the protector of the tribe there's
there's plenty of alpha men and you know
who they are at a distance I would say
Elon Musk is an alpha man I never hear
Elon Musk okay so you said something
interesting about gorillas there how
they protect the tribe but there's also
an Us Versus Them component to that
right like there's you're on the inside
this is my Herm these are my women these
are my children and this is what I love
and I protect and the gorillas will
destroy anything on the outside that
looks like that it's threatening to his
tribe right so he's not interested in
protecting anything else out there so
what you describe is a man that has
identified an Us Versus Them Dynamic and
protects us um I think in gorillas they
protect the entire tribe that they're
within including yeah they Harum and
their offspring anything that's not part
of that is them and it's on the outside
of the perimeter and is
destroyed I mean okay so right but with
the point we're trying by your
definition an alpha doesn't Embrace
everything right I'm not saying that you
should embrace everything I just you
started off saying that an alpha doesn't
say things like that I don't think that
the way to build yourself up as an alpha
is to try to take down other people yeah
but how was that trying to take down
other people by making a statement of
fact you think that's a statement of
fact it's a women's Bea lose
value I said women's Beauty deteriorates
after 23 you said they hit a wo yeah and
it and it deteriorates after a certain
age and then they have to come to a
realization at some point that that
exists and they start to do something
about it and they usually shift their
behavior right you know this is usually
when women start spending money on their
looks and makeup and get a breast
augmentation things like this
right I mean you don't have to I I don't
get your point
necessarily well the realization that
beauty goes on the decline is when women
start H start having to modify their
behavior they have to start lowering
their expectations like one of the
things that you'll start to notice in
some of the older shows is that when we
have some of the gals on that have sort
of unplugged and subscribed to a lot of
the conversations and the topics that I
offer solutions to um because I mean you
either disagree with me or you agree
with them me I think the vast majority
of women tend to disagree with me
because it doesn't serve their agenda um
it's usually when I start hearing things
like a real man or he's a beta and it
and it and it gets like distilled down
to like um pointing and sputtering right
um it doesn't really deal with like the
issue in a conversational way where
you're solving the problem or offering a
better solution so um I mean you've said
this and I'm and I'm trying to
understand well okay so you're still
seeing it from this perspective but what
was wrong about what was
said you asked me specifically why I
thought you were Beta And I responded
with the fact that that comment is the
only thing I knew about you up until
that point and it's like oh this guy's
calling calling himself an alpha and yet
I don't call myself an alpha you show me
where I've said that I've called myself
an
alpha I don't I don't get to make those
decisions people are the one that look
at you and say well that person's
exhibits Alpha behaviors that person
exhibits more plugged in beta type of
behaviors did I did is your name on on
social media something alpha or your
your show something Alpha where did the
title of the book is the unplugged Alpha
the title of the podcast on this channel
is the unplugged Alpha but do I say
Rich no but do I say Rich where I got
from yeah you're you literally like your
show in your book is called Alpha so I
assume it's called the unplugged Alpha
it's it's a descriptive term it's a
placeholder to describe the behaviors
and the ideas that are adopted that
serve you better in life because I think
you would agree that Society lies to us
right like they tell women to put off
childbearing like I saw a tweet where
you said something like don't have your
kids when you're 40 it's not going to
happen like are you okay in the head
like you have them younger right so you
like that but I I I do say that that
women should have their children I think
my children are the best thing I've ever
done and I think that women should
absolutely if they want children have
them once in your 40s fting ideologies
around there where you say things like
um you know you have to take ownership
for yourself because you can't rely on a
man because if a man steps out or he
does something that's offside you have
to be able to look after yourself so you
have to be a boss girl at the same time
so how are you a feminine compliment to
his life and a woman if you're adopting
masculine traits and behaviors right
like one of the things um you hear a lot
of women say is that I'm strong
successful I'm independent I have my own
house I have my own car I have my own
business and it's like you know when
they start to describe these things and
they're broadcasting them as if they're
proud of them and it's what creates
value in their life beyond just their
beauty what they're essentially doing is
they describing a man right strong
successful can take care of [__] Can
Make It Rain can make it happen those
aren't conventional feminine traits
those are more masculine traits so what
are convention feminine traits and where
would you like to see a woman in life
Rich well conventionally feminine traits
are women that are typically more or
less a compliment to a man's life right
like they're useful to his life they're
not a a not the focus of his life or or
distraction from his purpose or his
grind
right I mean
so how does that fit in let's see um so
a woman is only useful to his life if
he's she's a compliment to it but you
don't want a woman who is necessarily
able to support herself like where where
are you going with this like it's not
feminine if you have your own business
for example it's not feminine if you are
able to to support yourself um I've
never said I'm strong on contrary I
think that that um women feminine women
aren't strong I don't know where that
strong woman thing comes from maybe
other women say it it's definitely not
something I've said um women should be
able to support themselves if that is
the choice that they make I'm I'm a
strong proponent of women staying home
taking care of kids and relying on their
husband but at the same time you need to
have some type of protection if you are
a man who wants family law protect you
if you have to untie the
knot It generally looks after mothers
and children very very well doesn't it
it not necessarily no not in my case
absolutely not I'm confused because the
way family law works is that if you're a
stay-at-home parent and you don't have
any income and you're raising the kids
um the court in the State of Florida is
the only one that I know and I'm not a
lawyer so um any lawyers welcome to
correct me in the State of Florida we
got rid of alimony for example and
there's no rec that just happened in
that's also not true we got rid of
permanent alimony lifetime alimony
alimony still exists wasn't it just in
the last six months that the stist made
that announcement yeah and it was
lifetime Perpetual alimony that got Shu
down so you're you know that well okay
like I said I'm not a lawyer so you know
well my divorce is over 10 years ago um
I think that again if you're going to go
down that path and you're going to rely
on a man then you need some assurances
if you are not going to be able to
support yourself and you're going to
make family law the government ensures
that I really hope you guys enjoyed that
clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're newer to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out